get ready for plot holes lots and lots
of plot holes in the opening scene we
are introduced to Andy who has just
arrived in Morocco to meet one of her
team members Booker Booker informs her
about their new assignment involving the
rescue of kidnapped girls in South Sudan
he tells her that a former CIA operative
named James Copley is freelancing these
kinds of jobs and wants them to do it
Andy initially refuses to take the job
because it is against their rule never
work for the s same employers twice
however Booker persuades her to at least
come to the hotel and talk to the rest
of their teammates Nikki and Joe upon
arrival the group is Overjoyed to meet
each other after a long while the rest
of them seem to be willing to take the
job but Andy doesn't trust James as a
result they decide to have a meeting
with James to gather more information on
this matter in the next scene Andy and
Booker meet James at a local restaurant
while Nikki and Joe keep an eye on them
maintaining a sniper position James
explained exps the situation to them and
asserts how they can make a difference
in the world suspicious Andy asks for
the reason why James left the CIA to
which he responds that his sick wife
passed away and ever since he couldn't
bring himself to go back hearing all of
this Andy despite her reservations
ultimately agrees to take the job the
crew then sets off on their mission to
South Sudan via helicopter they arrive
there in the evening and wait for the
right time to infiltrate the kidnappers
base as the night falls they silently
neutralize the guards and make their way
into the basement much to their surprise
they find no hostages in the bunker and
instead they notied that they are under
CCTV surveillance this makes them
realize that they've been set up but
before they can react they are ambushed
by a group of armed military force who
unload their guns on the four of them
the crew collapses to the ground
seemingly dead the military force then
turns their backs believing that they
are dead but in an unexpected turn of
events the four of them start start to
heal at a rapid Pace expelling bullets
from their bodies they soon get on their
feet and take down all the armed forces
in a matter of seconds all of this is
witnessed by James from the camera it's
like a superhero movie but it's not it's
fresh it's Netflix in the aftermath the
crew buries their bloodied clothes in
the sand before boarding a train during
their discussion about their next steps
Andy claims that they must find James
because he knows who they are here it's
revealed that the four of them are s y
old warriors with unexplained
regenerative healing abilities they Ed
their vast experience to work as
mercenaries taking missions that help
people this is the first time that their
secret abilities have been disclosed
simultaneously in Afghanistan a squad of
marine soldiers led by Nile is tasked
with investigating a group of women
believed to be held captive by a
terrorist during interrogation a woman
silently gestures towards a room where
the terrorist seems to be hiding as a
result the soldiers break into the room
and shoot the enemy in the chest NY then
proceeds to check his pockets but the
terrorist fatally slits her throat back
on the train the four super Warriors
share a dream of Nile's death which
makes them realize that she's one of
them Andy then instructs the three of
them to find James while she goes to get
Nile on the other hand we learn that
Nile has survived as she wakes up in a
medical tent her teammates are shocked
when they notice that she doesn't even
have a scratch from the injury as a
result they decide to send her to
Germany for more testing this news
saddens NY because Germans do weird
tests so she sits in a corner and
listens to her favorite song to calm
herself down but before she is
transferred Andy tracks her down and
puts her at gunpoint Nile asks about her
identity to which she introduces herself
as andromachi of cyia because if it's
not dorky as hell it's not believable
she then knocks her down before
abducting her from the military base a
while later Nile regains consciousness
and finds herself in the trunk of an
army vehicle in an attempt to escape she
kicks open the trunk and jumps out Andy
notices this and stops the vehicle she
then shoots her in the back of the head
and waits for her to recover when Nile
finally opens her eyes Andy tells her to
accompany her if she wants the answers
the scene then cuts to England where we
are introduced to a pharmaceutical
executive named Steven Merrick who is
giving a presentation to potential
donors for stem cell research he tells
them that he has the technology capable
of Eric ating human disease and
extending lifespan all he needs is
investment after the presentation ends
James who is also present there shows
the video of Immortals to Steven this
leaves the ladder in shock so he orders
James to capture the team as soon as
possible looks like my half brother and
his magic butthole friends are at it
again meanwhile Andy and Nile board a
drug trafficking plane and make their
way to the rendevu point Paris Nile
still doesn't believe in Andy and think
that she drugg Ed her with something
however she is speechless when Andy
reminds her of the terrorist who slit
her throat following this Andy takes a
nap during which Nile secretly ties her
to the chair and holds the pilot at
gunpoint she threatens him to land right
now when Andy realizes what's going on
she comes up with a brilliant plan she
asks the pilot to play dead and then
fakes a shot making it look like a
murder this obviously freaks Nile out
but Andy assures her that she can fly
the plane as a result the scared girl
reluctantly ier but she soon realizes
that it was a ruse the two then engage
in a duel but Andy being an experienced
and professional fighter over Powers her
she finally convinces Nile to join their
team pointing out that she is no longer
a marine anymore she's now an angry
Immortal charity worker upon Landing in
Paris they head to an abandoned church
where Nile meets the remaining crew over
dinner she learns more about their
immortality Booker before Nile was the
youngest Immortal from the 18th Century
while Nikki and Joe have been together
since the 12th century the oldest
Immortal is none other than Andy as they
Converse she reveals that they are not
truly Immortal their ability to heal
eventually stops without warning which
is what happened to a guy named lyen
that night Nile experiences a disturbing
dream that awakens the entire crew she
recounts dreaming of a woman confined in
an iron coffin drowning in the middle of
the sea the crew informs her that she
dreamt of the female immortal cing Andy
then reveals that when she and queen
were attempting to free women accused of
Witchcraft hundreds of years ago they
were caught and accused of Witchcraft
themselves when the town's people
realized that they couldn't kill the two
of them they separated them Andy somehow
managed to flee the Captivity while coin
was locked in an iron coffin and tossed
into the sea since then she has been
drowning and Reviving in an endless loop
hearing all of this a visibly Disturbed
Nile walks out to take some time alone
but she's followed by Andy suddenly a
group of soldiers dispatched by James
arrive at the church upon hearing a
sound Andy and nyall get back inside
only to discover that Joe and Nikki have
been taken away leaving an injured
Booker behind it turns out Booker has
been blown up by a grenade and his
injury is very deep due to this it will
take him a little longer to heal as he
regenerates Andy kills all of their
asants one by one after she returns they
pack up their things and make their way
to another Hideout meanwhile Joe and
Nikki are taken to James in England who
then takes them to Steven's research lab
Steven explains that he intends to use
them for stem cell research and will
conduct experiments on them to unravel
their regenerative abilities he also
asks James to bring Andy and Booker
while Nikki and Joe are sent to the lab
after extracting all the samples they
need for their experiment James asks
Steven to release them but the latter
refuses out of selfishness Dudley has
always been a bully boy on the other
hand Andy Nile and Booker arrive at
another Hideout while Booker tries to
locate James via his computer Andy
notices that she's still bleeding from
the wound sustained earlier realizing
that she isn't healing she walks out to
a pharmacy and buys a bunch of Med
supplies she then returns back to her
car and takes some time to Grapple with
the realization that her immortality has
waned on that same night Nile wakes up
from another bad dream and steps outside
for some fresh air there she finds Andy
and the two talk about their families
also Express the pain of being Immortal
their conversation is soon interrupted
by bucker who claims to have located
James's whereabouts wasting no time the
trio drives towards the same but as they
prepare to break in Nile refuses to join
them she says that she's got a family
and wants to be with them before it's
too late this time Andy lets her go even
allowing her to take the car and a
pistol following this Nile heads to the
train station while Andy and bucker
enter the building to confront James
once they find him Andy demands
information about her friend's
whereabouts at this point Booker
unexpectedly shoots her from behind and
ties her up he then admits that he set
this up because he thinks Steven might
find a way to end their immortality
however he starts to panic upon seeing
that Andy isn't healing shortly after
Steven and his men walk in and capture
the two super Warriors James tries to
protest highlighting Andy's non-healing
State and her potential death however
Steven doesn't seem to care as he is
willing to torture the Immortals
indefinitely to study them when James
continues to insist he is knocked down
by the guards Steven then takes Andy and
Booker to his lab and restrains them
alongside the other crew members
elsewhere Nile arrives at the station
but she soon finds out that her pistol
is empty realizing Booker's betrayal she
heads back to James's place and demands
to know what's going on James then
confesses that he has been doing
research on Andy and her crew he also
tells her about all the good things
they've done for Humanity he thought of
helping the World by apprehending them
but he was wrong now that he has a
change of heart he decides to help Nile
in rescuing her crew members James then
leads her to Steven's highly secured
research lab he briefs Nile about the
patrolling guards and the research lab
situated on the 15th floor he also hands
her a master card that can access any
door of the building with this Nile arms
herself with a gun and begins fighting
the guards making her way in she soon
locates the crew members and frees them
the five or together again and they make
their way towards Steven taking down all
the guards on their way this time the
team prioritizes protecting Andy because
she can't heal if she gets shot they
eventually break into Steven's office
but don't find him there just then they
notice the elevator going down so Booker
Nikki and Joe pursue via stairs while
Nile stays with Andy however it turns
out to be a trick as Steven confronts
the two women holding them at gunpoint
just when it seems that the bad guy is
about to win now n and Andy come up with
a plan they actually perform the same
trick from the plane Andy plays dead
which acts as a distraction earning Nile
enough time to tackle him she then grabs
Steven and jumps off the 15th floor
before landing on a car crash may not
have killed Lil and James po but that
fall sure as killed Duds a while
later she slowly recovers and comes to
life while Steven is killed in the
aftermath the group drives away from the
scene and pulls over at a restaurant to
discuss Booker's fate after a while of
deliberation Andy talks to bucker in
private and tells him that they have
decided his punishment the group
sentences him to loneliness forbidding
him from contacting them for the next
100 years Andy and bucker then share an
emotional hug as they both know that
they won't see each other ever again
after this the rest of the group members
meet with James who explains how his
research revealed that their past
missions had a greater effect than they
ever knew according to him the
descendants of the people whom they had
rescued are going on to help the world
in many different ways with renewed
faith in their existence the group
allows James into their team Andy
instructs him to maintain their secret
and find missions where they can have an
effect 6 months later in Perry a
depressed and drunk Booker returns to
his apartment only to be greeted by coin
sequel no let's let's you know